now this morning essential workers are
under orders to get covert vaccinations
president biden received his booster
shot in front of cameras at the white
house yesterday in new york a court
approved a vaccine mandate for teachers
while tens of thousands of medical
workers can now be fired if they don't
get shots errol barnett is outside linux
hill hospital in new york city errol
good morning
hey there nate good morning at midnight
the state's vaccine mandate for
healthcare workers went into effect but
some health systems like northwell
health behind me already dismissed some
two dozen unvaccinated staffers now
though other systems will have 30 days
to allow their employees to get the jab
or lose their job
theon vaccinated are officially out of
time at new york state's medical
facilities with 16 percent of the
state's hospital workers not fully
vaccinated that means more than 83 000
are at risk of termination do you feel
then it takes a mandate to get everybody
vaccinated i do think so stephen corwin
is president and ceo at new york
presbyterian hospitals one of the
largest systems in the country before
its own vaccination deadline last week
30 percent of staff were unvaccinated
but after the deadline less than one
percent refused the shot and resigned so
out of forty eight thousand
uh employees and affiliated physicians
we have less than two hundred and twenty
that have not chosen to get the vaccine
at erie county medical center in buffalo
about five percent of the staff roughly
400 people are unvaccinated and on leave
hospital president and ceo tom quitrochi
we stopped elective inpatient surgeries
we stopped some of our outpatient visits
we stopped icu medical transfers from
other referring rural hospitals we've
asked for more time and work on
strategies with the state to ensure that
as many people as possible get
vaccinated
at a press conference monday governor
kathy hochul announced plans to send
national guard troops to short-staffed
hospitals like ecmc
i'm wearing the same exact ppe i've worn
the whole pandemic and it's always kept
myself and patients safe
why is it change debra conrad is a nurse
in western new york suing the state over
its vaccine mandate she's still
uncomfortable with getting the shot are
you prepared to lose your job a career
that i've loved for almost 20 years i am
prepared
now it's important to remember here that
more than six billion vaccine doses have
been administered worldwide so we have
overwhelming data now that says these
vaccines are safe and effective for most
people now um here in new york state
there is a vaccine mandate for education
workers that goes into effect i should
say here in new york city that goes into
effect later this week the teachers
union tells us 97 percent of its members
are vaccinated and the city says over
the weekend some seven thousand
education workers tony rushed to get
their vaccines
some good news errol thank you very much